More than 20 million children worldwide are
suffering from severe malnutrition.
And just giving them food is not going to
help.
Hey Everybody, I'm Carin for DNews with some
stunning new information on the long-term
effects of malnourishment.
In the Western world we are not accustomed
to dealing with severe cases of starvation;
however, in South Central Asia and many other
first world countries it is a problem of epic
proportions.
In Bangladesh, more than 40% of children under
the age of 5 are affected by either severe
or moderate malnutrition.
It's well known that undernourished children
suffer its ill effects into later life and
even adulthood.
Long term symptoms include stunted growth,
cognitive problems and weakened immune systems.
Scientists have recently discovered that these
health issues are rooted in lingering, underdeveloped
collections of gut microbes.
We have a lot of of 'friendly' microbes in
our digestive systems, tens of trillions of
them!
These microbes help us to efficiently harvest
energy and calories from food.
They also help to regulate our metabolism,
synthesize vitamins and shape our immune systems.
It's almost like a massive digestive machine
located within our guts, and the components
of this machine are established during early
childhood.
Malnourishment in small children means that
the machine doesn't form correctly, and it
can't simply be synthesized later in life
by supplying a diet of nutrient-rich food.
A recent study looked at the gut microbes
from fecal samples from children in under
the age of 5, both well nourished and malnourished.
From this data, researchers were able to identify
groups of bacteria that assemble in the gut
within the first two years of life.
Further, study subjects were then given therapeutic
foods that are generally used for treatment
of starvation, and fecal samples were continuously
monitored.
Once the children had gained sufficient weight,
they were removed from food supplements but
fecal samples were monitored for a further
four months.
Researchers found that once the therapeutic
foods were removed from the diet, gut bacteria
regressed back to a more immature community.
So, critical next steps will include the development
of therapies to replace a mature gut bacterial
community on a long-term or permanent basis.
What do you think about the fact that 20 million
children around the world are malnourished?
How can we do more to help?
Leave your suggestions in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe here for more
Dnews.